but yeah how was uh how's Vietnam Joe
um yeah so as I was saying uh it's hot
as hell in Japan right now I mean we've
talked about you know summer here we've
done entire episodes
crushing the Japanese summaries I didn't
know like there was like a dark souls
level of hotness until I went to Vietnam
in the middle of June welcome to
Southeast Asia like I wasn't sweating I
was perspiring like yeah it was
inspiring
person
it was raining perspiring it was raining
from my face it was disgusting like I'm
pretty sure I made like my own cloud
system just because of just how [__]
sweaty it was you should take a Nick
card avocado he's got a little water
weight
dude it was weird like I ate okay so
obviously I'm on vacation right that's
my whole family's on vacation so when
you're on vacation mode you don't care
about what you eat all right yeah right
so you just go ham on every all the food
right because I wanted to have the most
it was my first time Vietnam I wanted to
get all of the authentic Vietnamese food
right yeah some of it's healthy of
course and some of it isn't whilst I was
like [__] it I'll just get everything
and somehow even though I haven't gorged
myself that much in I'd say at least the
past three or four months I somehow
still lost weight you're probably
walking around because of you know I
mean we went on some hikes but also I
think just during the day I'm sweating
like 10 liters so like legit like
nicocado if you want to lose some weight
Bros
this is [__] advice you want to lose
that water weight bro you'll lose it
immediately we were in America like I
noticed that like I was walking more on
average in America than I was when I'm
here in Japan yeah it doesn't make any
[__] sense
well because I I we we were doing this
wow yeah yeah that's right laundry's
house is huge yeah uh well everything I
was doing involved me being standing up
and walking around even if it's just
like a little bit like I was just doing
a lot more walking like in Japan when
I'm streaming I'll sit there and I'll
look and I'll be like wow oh
what happens when you touch grass you
know it's like it's like if you just sit
in all day
we were just doing stuff I was doing
stuff every single day so I was always
walking every day even if I was ubering
there I would then had to walk because
like in America you know uh it's
actually you still have to walk along
you're like oh the parking lot is
[__] 900 meters long and you're like
oh [__] okay well that's that's 500
steps right there you know it's like
there's you they sneak it in you don't
realize it everything actually is
[__] spread out so goddamn much I
think I think the conclusion from this
is that you need to be walking more
while you're in Japan no no because I I
think I usually you can take from this
is more in America but he is a very
small percentage of people the people
that stream yeah they'll work from home
and stream all day and do not go outside
if you go to America then you end up
walking more unless you're in America
and you stream all day as well so I'm
actively trying to not go outside right
now and if I do it's like the taxi is
the buffer like I like I'm getting in
that I'm going because I don't want to
be outside it sucks oh you would have
hated in Vietnam yeah I would have I
would have I mean the hottest day we had
was when I was in Saigon and it was like
46 degrees [__] that and that's not
including the humidity I'm going to tell
anyone
oh my God it was like I never felt like
my life was in danger from heat yeah
until I went to Vietnam like just
stepping outside not even in the sun in
the shade right because the humidity
here is bad but somehow Vietnam was just
like we can get hotter when it comes to
humanity so like it there was literally
no difference between standing in the
Sun and standing in the chair you just
felt like there was a heater attached to
your face at all times and it was
disgusting oh I'm surprised because
normally like for Thailand at least uh
July period is actually like one of the
cooler periods because it's rainless
it's rainy season in Thailand yeah uh
like the hottest seasons are kind of
actually maybe maybe um maybe even think
of May but they're like there is a
definite not hot periods but the best
period to go to like southeast Asia is
kind of around like February kind of
like period yeah well I mean when we
went to Thailand in January it was great
yeah yeah that was like that was perfect
I was like actually like nice you could
like breathe and yeah yeah
exactly yeah right but yeah California
was great weather too though yeah yeah
California we did not we didn't have a
heat wave this time uh there was no kind
of like it's hot but then you go in
shade and you're like oh yeah it's uh
it's bearable yeah it's a shareable but
uh the important the question is did you
rent a moped see I really wanted to
because I'd heard about God's stories of
like riding in a moped and almost dying
and I was like I want that near-death
experience and I tried but because I was
with my family I asked my mom
ah and she was like well you know it's
my birthday and I don't want you to die
on my birthday
you did that you did the wrong thing you
should have asked for forgiveness yeah
but like you know I was really down my
dad was like kind of down uh my sister
and my mom were just like no I don't
want to die so unfortunately I couldn't
but hopefully next time
if we go back to yeah if we go back to
Vietnam in the summer that's what I'm
I'm hearing I'm drunk now oh my god dude
you would have been like every time
every time I walked past like uh
foreigners were in uh Vietnam because
there was like a surprising amount of
foreigners during that time of year I
was like I thought for sure everyone was
gonna try and avoid the summer heat but
yeah there was a lot of people there
wasn't it like don't they get [__] tons
of tourists because it's super cheap
well yeah that too but yeah but it's
cheap all year round right so you'd
think you'd try and aim for like you
know January February time like people
like normally like to take summer
holidays you know like Europe it's like
a culture of going on holiday in the
summer yeah it's like Summer's the time
oh my God yeah but every time I started
European tourists and they look like
they wanted to kill themselves they were
just like it never gets hot here yeah it
never gets hot at home like this I can't
imagine them surviving Southeast Asian
Summers like that oh my God they will
not survived yeah it was bad but other
than the heat everything else was
[__] amazing I went to uh what is
considered to be the best ban me
restaurant or I guess place in all of
Vietnam it's a place in Hoi An that uh
Farm is just like the they're like the
sandwiches like sandwiches Vietnamese
sandwiches but apparently this one is
high the highest rated or the best in
all of Vietnam because Anthony Bourdain
went to it and uh yes
opinion what it was so weird because
well yeah I found that really weird
because I was like when we were at the
hotel in Hoi An and I was like oh we
really want to get some like good
Vietnamese food where do you recommend
there's four Vietnamese like guy at the
front desk was just like have you ever
heard of Anthony
he recommended this place in Hoi An I
wonder if they were like hey my cousin
says this one's the best yeah I don't
know who's that the white guy yeah I was
expecting like a super local place right
but it's just like no go to this place
that the white man says oh no man I've
seen how Gordon Ramsay Cooks apart Thai
man
I'm seeing that video when I'm like okay
highly respected
like there's so there's a video where I
Gordon Ramsay goes to this like Thai
restaurant and it Cooks the pad thai and
the chefs and I I remember the first
time watching it I've never had such an
uncle Rogers kind of like reaction to
someone cooking my contacts I'm like
this is not Pad Thai and thank God the
Thai Chef who was you know very politely
uh very politely said this is not how uh
we may play offensive I don't know
he he tried to politely work it and to
be to be fair to Gordon Ramsay he did
very much you know take his advice on
how to cook a pot side but you know I if
Anthony Bourdain says this is the best
ban me restaurant in Vietnam I'm gonna
call sauce on that yeah it was also
really weird because like because I saw
the clip of like the actual episode
where he actually went there you know
just the double check this was the right
place yeah apparently I didn't have to
because the moment I got to this place
in front of it there's this huge like A3
[__] poster of Anthony Bourdain just
like deep throating upon me and right
next to it in this like curse of text it
was it was a quote from Anthony Bourdain
and it did us and it said the best
baguette I've ever had
and I thought has Anthony Bourdain never
been to France
has he never been to Europe because I'm
not too sure that was a mistranslation
they were like they're like I think he's
a baguette actually yeah
maybe Bond me in Vietnamese equals
baguette I don't know but I was like
okay you know what oh look I'll take the
benefit of that I'll go in to be fair it
was the best barmy I've ever had yeah
and we went to a couple of places in
Vietnam as well and obviously outside of
Vietnam and I would say you know what he
wasn't fully capping but I'm sure some
Vietnamese you know people are going to
be like no no that one's overrated go to
this one it's definitely got to be some
careful people when sometimes people
come to Japan and then like they've been
here like four or five times they'll be
like dude I know like the best spot to
eat and I'm like okay tell me and then
they'll just send me something and it'll
be like a really well-known restaurant
it'll be like something that everyone
knows about that is just pretty okay and
it's like there's another [__] this
is not a find yeah this is you went on
Google and typed in sushi restaurants
but yeah it's I'm very skeptical when
somebody who visits a place like this is
the best place here it's like you don't
know [__] yeah my favorite one though
and that was the other thing I loved
about Vietnam is uh and obviously this
gets memes a lot uh in like Western
countries with that have Vietnamese
restaurants it's just like some of them
just have the best [__] names for
restaurants I went to this restaurant
in Sapa when we did this like three-day
hike in the mountains
um beautiful place definitely go but uh
there was just this restaurant right
next to our hotel just called yummy
restaurant
was a yummy restaurant and I kid you not
it was yummy I mean actually no problem
here yeah yeah yeah
all right I mean you weren't lying this
was a yummy restaurant it was just very
weird though when you look up on Google
and the first thing that comes up is
yummy restaurant well I feel like you
know I've seen this quite a lot in uh
Thailand at least where sometimes if you
just want to make your restaurant stand
out uh you know like you know if you
open a Thai restaurant here in you know
a foreign country you want to like a
Thai name to it uh but over there if you
just put like a [__] English name
that's what makes it stand out you know
we don't want the traditional Thai name
we want like the foreign name the wacky
foreign
I remember seeing all those weird
statues like they would have like
one-to-one size statues of like Thor
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I was like why
don't you
just have like a normal normal ass
restaurant but in front of it it's just
like just dudes like like Captain
America being rammed by like Tony Stark
or something
a one-to-one statue so every [__]
Google pick of the restaurant is just a
statue of like a copyrighted Disney
character just being raw dogged and so
then that way if everyone want to post
about your place and people are gonna go
there and all I have to do is commission
a statue of like maybe like I don't know
well just like the most cursed [__]
imaginable it's like super it's like
Mario like on his knees in front of
Luigi yeah and he's like oh I'm doing
his pants and his one-to-one scale and
like that's the picture that everyone's
commit like making out with Mickey Mouse
yeah or like Mario Sonic Mario
one-to-one statue and like you can't
avoid it because people are gonna see it
and post about it sure and and you can
do it in these places because nobody's
crank clapping down these copyrighted
yeah foreign happened when I was in Hoi
An uh there was this [__] bar that
was like themed around Mr Bean oh was he
making out with someone no no no
it's too legit to the gym when it was
like the entire bar like all the drinks
all the food was themed around Mr Bean
and I'm like I don't think this got the
all clear from like yeah that's not
enough yeah you need something like
absolutely out there but that also won't
get a shut down because I assume there's
gonna be a limit right yeah but I mean
you still want people to come to your
restaurant you know you don't want to be
having like a nice little meal and then
you just look and it's just Marion Sonic
making out and you're just like I don't
know man I don't know
so it's like it's like Mario Sonic
making out in front and then you get in
and then on the roof it's like two
Spidermans in that one Spider-Man meme
where he's like slapping his ass in the
bed but on the roof and the whole
restaurant is just absolutely [__]
copyright characters just going at it
and that way everyone wants to come in
and see what's going on and they sit
down there and when I charge like I rip
off all the tourists as well I think
this is a great idea yeah another thing
as well that I noticed about it is that
um like you know the concept of happy
hour right yeah and like a bar yeah
right like normally what what would what
would you say is like the average time
of unhappy hour they scam you it's like
3 P.M on a Monday yeah but 3 P.M like
usually right when you go to like any
Western Country happy hours usually I
don't know between maybe like
four and seven maybe five and seven it's
a couple never happy hour it's never
seven so Seven's two not generous it
stops at like six yeah I saw a
restaurant in Saigon dead ass right in
front of the store big sign happy hour 9
A.M to 8 p.m and I'm like when is it not
happening at that point every hour is
happy yeah just say we have free we have
free drinks we're just coming they're
just happy how happy are you we are
happy during these hours there's not a
lot of work because we're open yeah they
misunderstood the concept of Happiness
they clearly didn't know what happy hour
happy hour means we're open right it's
actually stressful for us after this
time so please actually be more
considerate after this but I went in and
sure enough the guy was like yeah uh buy
two get one free that's fine and we were
there like 12. and I was like how how
are you surviving as as a business well
I mean uh I mean if people are coming
there at like 9 A.M you must be doing
something right yeah
what was your favorite place in Vietnam
then oh geez that's hard I probably have
to say Sapa um it's like right on the
northern border of Vietnam yeah
um it's called it's called the city in
the clouds because it's like the
elevation of this entire Village is like
a thousand meters up awesome um and it's
like there's just these like clouds
rolling over the hills it looks like a
[__] Princess Mononoke Scene It was
so sick um and we went on this like
two-day hike down into the valley to
like go to all of the um indigenous
Vietnamese Villages
um and like kind of went around there
that was like [__] amazing like that
if you like hiking like for sure go
there
um I hate hiking though and Hiking
[__] jungle you're like hiking in
something like Asia we were like Dennis
in the jungle I've done that once and I
think I almost got a heat stroke because
I'm like how do I how do I cool off I
can't I can't splash water on myself
because that's like the atmosphere is
already doing yeah so I'm like it
actually sounds like my
but then on the second day it was like
raining quite a bit and I was just like
oh thank God oh yeah thank you yeah I I
love the rain in Southeast Asia because
you're like you can literally feel like
the climate like going down a few
degrees yeah you're like oh my God but
but the problem was it was a
double-edged sword because it was like I
I was calling down from the rain but the
this entire hike we were in in the
jungle is like mud so I'm basically like
ankle or like almost like yeah ankle
deep in mud I wore my vessels and uh you
know those survive so I definitely gave
them like the best [__] promo they've
ever had because I came out of this hike
like my [__] shoes were muddy as [__]
still good it's not a single drop on my
socks literally sounds like my nightmare
yeah
it was fantastic though like it was
definitely a hot hike but like just
getting to see this like insane looking
like views yeah it just didn't look real
but it was yeah [__] amazing yeah
yeah maybe I don't recommend for people
doing like I love hiking so I enjoy the
[__] out of it but yeah I I realized
especially when uh when I went on the
ski trip I was like oh so skins kind of
like you get all the advantages of
hiking except yeah no actually hiking
why people love it yeah I was like yo
why yeah yeah why people are on to
something man
chill you can drink Max hiking yeah you
you have the fun part which is just
going down and then you can drink in
between get great views I think they
just build a device just to like get
like cut the hiking out what damn if
anything wasn't so expensive exactly
right oh this is this is it yeah hiking
is great if it's pay to win you know if
it's pay to win if it's pay to win like
for me it's like hiking is not a
vacation so hearing that this is a
vacation I'd be like no my head I'm like
this is like an activity and I wouldn't
want to do it as of it I don't know my
brain's weird like that I don't know I I
think I think for me like hiking can
definitely be uh like a roll because you
know it wasn't like we were like speed
running this hike or anything and it
wasn't like that long of a hike either I
think we did maybe like 10 15 kilometers
yeah um which is like nothing really but
you can get that done like half a day
um but I think like for me it was just
cool because you would never be able to
see these like traditional Villages or
like know anything about it like our
guide that took us was one of the
members of this like indigenous
Vietnamese Village and she just like
knew all the [__] shortcuts and [__]
and it was just so cool to just just be
able to see firsthand these like insane
environments that just like look
straight out of a video game yeah um so
like yeah it was tiring but is that what
you like about hiking the views yeah I
think like just if you're hiking I would
say like hiking in just like a forest
that you can't see the views from or
like you know if you don't hike to like
say the top of a mountain or whatever
then it's like okay yeah this is fine or
whatever but I think what I really enjoy
about hiking is just like when you pull
out of the really dense foresty areas
into an open area and you get to see
like where you got to and yeah the all
the views and [__] like that's really
gratifying for me it's just like oh I
[__] did it like I got to this place
and see this thing that I can only see
if I if only I had like gone through
this like trick right yeah because like
all these places were completely
inaccessible by anything other than foot
right so just to be able to say that
like you know I got to those places and
got to see it for myself as like I don't
know I find that really cool and
gratifying yeah I think that's why I
really like you know just like climbing
mountains and stuff as well going on
long walks and [__] yeah that's the part
I also like that's the only part I like
which is the views I don't like but to
say like I don't enjoy getting from
point A to point B in fact I [__]
despise it all the time you know like
like I'm not calling out hikers I get
the feeling of like holy [__] this is a
massive view but I am that [__]
who's going to complain from like like
the bottom to the top that's the British
I'm like I mean I get the views but I'm
not going to say I enjoy the experience
of hiking you know I don't know I like
especially when it's like a muddy Trail
or like you know an off-road Trail yeah
I really enjoyed like the challenge
aspect of it just being like oh cool got
through that and you know I didn't die
so it's like I don't know there's maybe
that's just me I don't know but that's
how I feel when I survive L.A I'm like
I made it to the next block without
dying oh yeah also I don't know I I
guess like another thing is like you
said you said muddy stuff I don't I
I I think I've kind of realized I
[__] hate muddy things or mud or
getting dirty I don't know it's it's
it's a weird thing
um city boy
I like EXO for me I like a very good
distinction like I am happy to get muddy
and dirty when I am I'm planning to do
that yeah but I don't like it when I go
to a place and it's like you're [__]
dirty and there's [__] everywhere and
like a like a hoarder's house it's like
that that kind of dirt or kind of stuff
like that I'm like that is am I I like
my worst like you don't like you don't
like when something is dirty in an
environment
but if you tell me hey Connor you gotta
go and [__] hike in the mud for three
days and be gross I'm like all right
cool yeah yeah I think I I only like
yeah I'm the same thing like I'm not
gonna [__] be walking down the street
in Tokyo and like be happy if someone
throws mod at me like I'm not I'm not
there it's like that's like I I don't
associate like being muddy is the same
part of my brain that like uh that
thinks like stuff so dirty right it's a
different
and all that kind of stuff and getting
dirty in that sense is is very different
in my head to how I view like
traditional like natural dirty well yeah
like messy stuff or kind of like you go
to a place like uh I don't know
sometimes you go to a place you're like
man I do I can't [__] comfortably in
this toilet it's not clean like yeah
stuff like that I think that's a big
reason why I just never went camping a
lot in the UK because I always
Associated it with you know I now that
I've been camping at other places I'm
like oh camping's so much fun but in the
UK it's just like you go out and it's
just like the floor is just muddy and
you just like especially if it's been
raining and then you just gotta Trek out
and you just never like I'm just never
comfortable you know yeah I get that
yeah that sounds I mean I love camping
but if you told me to go camping in the
UK I'd probably be like
it's cold yeah yeah no [__] that yeah if
I'm gonna go hiking normally I like a
trail I've never done like off-trail
hiking or anything like that so maybe
that might be fun because I'm the same
way if I if I know if I have time sounds
like mentally prepared to be like oh
you're just you're gonna get like down
and dirty and you're just gonna you know
[__] yourself up then I'm like okay at
least I have like preparation for that
yeah but if I just want to chill I'm
just like I'm I'm in like chill mode do
not do not disturb chill mode right now
yeah I mean you know we we definitely
had days in Vietnam where we were just
you know [__] hang out in the city
and just you know maybe go have a bite
to eat and just no physical activities
whatsoever but I think what was really
fun about this trip is that there was
kind of like a mixture of everything
like you know some days where we're just
like full on all day activity and then
there were some days where I was just
[__] sleeping you know like and not
doing anything going to the pool having
a drink at the you know at the bar or
whatever yeah
yeah that's that's the vacation I want
no physical activity that's uh yeah